on the show today i don't know we may
have him here after we get done talking
to rachel
the political strategist with strike
back you guys you guys have seen her
where she was here last week we did an
interview with her you got to go over
and subscribe to the youtube channel and
just keep tuning in as we bring rachel
in because she gives us everything that
we need everything that democrats need
here
breaking down week by week by week by
week telling us how we can win
so let's let's not waste a lot of time
let's bring rachel in here hey rachel
how are you
ah i'm good tony i got to tell you man
you've really set the bar with your
theme song for you oh really
you like you like the lead in huh i mean
how am i gonna copy that i'm gonna have
to send this off to some of my
my friends over in in the hw and be like
[ __ ] you gotta deliver me something
better
i can't have tony besting me on podcast
i mean it's so good dude it's so good
you mean the uh the the freedom to
oppress the rights of other people is
not liberty you [ __ ] eating morons yeah
so that actually that's a that's a good
story um that's how it all got started
as i did a tick tock and i said that in
a tick tock and everyone kind of grabbed
onto that and it's a good quote i don't
know if i came up with it or not but i
guess i coined the phrase so you know it
is what it is we got a lot of people
saying hi let's let's see if oh uh
caitlyn says hi rachel mj says hi rachel
yoda's saying hi you got some you got
some great fans here on our show i'm
almost kind of jealous robin says good
morning
so and we'd like to include all the
audience here on the show so i wanted to
cut real quick i usually go to
commercial and then bring you in but i
wanted to cut because i got i got a busy
day today we may have we just may have
the former guy come on the show today i
don't know it's possible he's in a
remote location you know he's getting
ready for his his uh government takeover
here did you did you watch some of the
clips
uh from the weekend
yeah sure did you know i mean yeah
i just i love though this is what i love
about it right
i mean i realize like people get upset
oh we shouldn't be talking about trump
or showing any more of his crazy [ __ ]
[ __ ] we shouldn't dude if you get if
you're if you're ari melber and you can
get one of these schmucks under criminal
investigation to show up and talk about
their [ __ ] on live national tv with a
trained lawyer you know you do that [ __ ]
dude and you know it's the same with
trump we gotta show people they're crazy
they don't aren't gonna just magically
know it in fact like many of the people
who want in even in 2020 i know this
seems so hard to believe dude but it's
true many people went into that ballot
in 2020 that did cast ballots for trump
and did it on very superficial
information like things that are you
know they aren't paying attention to any
of this [ __ ] so if we don't slap it in
front of their face and force them to
[ __ ] watch they're not getting
anymore
so do you think there are some voters
out there because you're looking in this
data right is there some voters out
there that voted for trump in 2016 and
2020 because that was all prior to
january 6. that was all prior to i want
to actually be a dictator type [ __ ] and
and kind of what we've seen this weekend
not only not only with him standing on
stage promising pardons which is
basically outright sedition um but also
his statement where he's like yes we
were trying to overthrow the government
of the united states like that was the
[ __ ] plan and we'll show that here
but do you think there are some voters
out there that voted for him they're
like nope too far this is that enough
can't do this well that's a really
complex question let me tell you this
not in the way that you're thinking and
not right maybe the audience is thinking
and certainly not the way that
democratic consultants think right um
because here's the thing like what you
can really see in data that most of the
exodus when when true i mean
electing and nominating donald trump
as your party's nominee the republican
party's nominee that was the moment
where that party really splintered from
reality
right right and so like um the part of
the realignment that was that could be
shaken loose kind of gets shaken loose
there and we really don't see
a lot of of loss after the general
election period of november and 16 we
see some declines but most of the exodus
of these white college educated people
who could not hang with this version of
the republican party natural exodus has
already occurred my argument is there
are more voters like that they are
ignoring uncomfortable news because it
would hurt them to know it right hurt
their feelings in their eyes
and if we force them to look and we
force them to look at my version of
messaging which is not like nothing the
left has ever run right then we can
maybe shake some more realignment juice
the way that they have done with
non-college educated white voters and
now non-educated voters non-college
educated voters across the board and we
we have to be running our own
sophisticated you know uh modernized
targeting and and it really is just
critical this time for us to do that but
yeah you can't just go to a trump i mean
this idea that trump voters that voted
for him in 2020
and 2020 and 2016
are suddenly now this is the thing right
right [ __ ] dude okay
so what you're saying is and i think the
point that we need to get across here
and the reason why i asked the question
is this isn't over like this fight in
the 2022 midterms and because they
i noticed what i noticed was that trump
and the republicans want to make
the 2024 race already the race and it's
like what we're not even 2 20 22 yet
we're
you know [ __ ] 2024 let's let's secure
the senate and and the house because
they're knocking on our front door these
nazis are knocking on the front door
like literally they're in florida like
you know putting up signs saying let's
go brandon and [ __ ] um let me see if i
can pull some of this stuff up here
uh here's the statement um that donald
trump made and you know i'm not gonna i
i you can go [ __ ] read it and you
everyone should read this [ __ ]
statement and the reason why is because
the last lines he could have overturned
the election
like he's saying out loud we wanted to
[ __ ] commit a cheeto dust kangaroo
coup like he's not even hiding it
anymore and of course
um as these criminal probes really
produce results um possibly uh of course
we can't count on that either but i said
tell me tell me you wanted to overthrow
the united states constitution by
telling me you wanted to overthrow the
united states constitution a lot of
people pissed off they're like oh quit
posting this and blah blah blah and i'm
like look
if i don't post his statements unless
he is [ __ ] admitting guilt and it
needs to be something that the american
people need to see and they need to
understand what he's saying like he is
saying here we tried to overthrow the
government and we would love to do it
again
no [ __ ] and here's the thing is what i
would say to people who don't like
to see um you know people platformed
right like these people are are like
committing like you know they're digging
legal holes every time they talk
and so there's you know there's actually
a functional strategic reason why we
want them to be
out talking in public as much as
possible and then insofar as like that
statement right i mean here's the thing
if you could get
some of these white college educated
voters that are still hanging on to like
their brand loyalty to the republican
party to to see [ __ ] like that i mean
that was written by a president like a
former president right it's you know
it's it's literally looney tunes right
and uh a lot of people just don't know
how they don't have a set they have a
sense like an imagistic sense of how bad
the republican party is getting but they
haven't had that clarified for them and
if they are
if we do that then we're at least asking
them to go into a referendum-style
election which is what a midterm is
making
you know a brand versus brand choice and
not brand versus this party says this on
policy right and we're going to lose
that fight for sure
well and and i i
what i i guess what i want you to do is
tell us
how how do
not not not the the establishment
democrats but people out there that are
are fighting for pro-democracy causes
the people knocking doors the people
wanting to see beto
win in texas right that's a governor's
race that's not a senate race that's not
that's not a a a house race for the
united states congress but it matters it
[ __ ] matters because that turnout is
going to be what we need and people have
to stay pissed and they have to go
[ __ ] vote so tell us why it's so
[ __ ] important to to make sure we
we straddle these [ __ ] republicans
with this anchor of
you are full-on [ __ ] fascist
tell us why that's important and how we
do that not not like politicians but the
people out there talking about this
posting on twitter or talking in their
churches their communities what do you
say how do you how do you make sure that
people understand what is at the front
door i mean here i'll answer it this way
this is how we know like the extent of
of like the danger we're in and the odds
that we face and that is the generic
ballot which asks you know americans do
you want republicans or democrats to
control congress and as long as that
number is tied or republican advantaged
which it is right now then we know this
for sure we know that out there in
normal america and again if you're
listening to my voice if you watch
tony's show if you follow me on twitter
i mean even if you read the washington
[ __ ] post you're not a normal
american you're not an average american
anyway at least in terms of civic and
and um news consumption so you know out
there obviously there's a disconnect
because people are saying hey i think
it'd be good to put the republicans in
control of congress
right because that's what that's what
the polls are showing right that's
that's that that's the the trajectory
here that's the trigger and then in
addition to that tony the other metric
is enthusiasm so when we look at
enthusiasm who's excited to vote
republicans have a 10 to 15 point
enthusiasm deficit or advantage over us
and that is the exact opposite of the
2018 midterm so i keep hearing analysts
say well in 2018 they they put pelosi on
everything and it didn't work out so
good for them i'm like yeah and watching
20 [ __ ] two it will look like the
most brilliant strategy in the world and
it's the same [ __ ] strategy it's just
the fundamentals that have changed right
right we really need to bring a
political science approach to our
election hearing because they're not
they're they're not going to come up
with like like a totally different plan
it's always the same [ __ ] right oh yeah
and their [ __ ] is so good i mean like so
here's the thing
you know crt that is a nationalized lab
created wedge issue that's going to be
deployed everywhere in the country every
[ __ ] race that's a swing race from
the school right on the way up and it
was created in the think tank it was
recognized for its its ambiguity right
what does it mean it means whatever the
[ __ ] you want it to mean that's right
right and it and it was it was
strategically deployed in virginia it's
not like the younkin campaign
and their consultants came up with this
strategy this is a rnc driven
strategic approach they're running
school board [ __ ] right now they're
throwing millions of dollars into these
fake grassroots moms of liberty school
board [ __ ] right and they're going
around and they're they're talking in
these districts they're talking in these
districts that aren't even theirs like
they don't even live in these districts
it's that strategic outrage that we
talked about last night and what they're
doing tony is they're keeping those
embers burning for the fall for crt and
so this is [ __ ] we can all see coming
and we can plan and strategically
counteract is right argument right if we
can see it coming and so it then so when
i look at when people ask me today
rachel are we going to win congress i
say no absolutely not and we know that
for a [ __ ] fact because the general
you're [ __ ] scared
and we have a 15-point enthusiasm gap
and so what i'm arguing for the
strategic approach i want to come in and
bring is
my strategy
despite all the micro elements of it at
the macro level is designed to deal with
those two indicators
right so
so
we we we um we implore that strategic
outrage but
they are giving us [ __ ] just gift
after gift after gift i want to show you
something here um that shannon watts um
post yes
and this is uh shannon says in case you
didn't hear there's a nazi rally in
orlando today this is in florida of
course the rise of authoritarian banned
books armed insurrections demagogues and
disinformation american 20 2022 has a
lot more in common with 1930s germany
than many are willing to admit here's
the picture
um if you look here it says vax the jews
oh that's cute and then up here it has
nazi um you
i can't believe nobody is including that
because holy crap right and you know
what i would do with this [ __ ]
is i would take it i would mean it and i
would slap republican party platform on
that [ __ ] too and i would [ __ ] send
it out you know that's what they would
do to us so right i i i don't think it's
a bad idea so any of you meme
meme makers out there start posting this
[ __ ] everywhere
everywhere political cartoonist i mean
we we have you know propaganda is always
a bad word right like in in you know
it's always a bad word like really
honestly they use propaganda and
misinformation in a way
that that totally [ __ ] brainwashes
people i mean i watched a video of a guy
with a cardboard cutout of [ __ ] trump
on a segway at his rally like he was
humping the guy or something like what
in the actual hell is going on like no
one i have never seen a democrat
never seen a democrat worship a
cardboard cutout of joe biden have you i
don't i don't think that exists but they
do
and it's because they use propaganda in
a way and they use information in a way
to get inside these people's skulls and
we can use the same way we just don't
have to use misinformation and hate and
bigotry we can use the truth and it can
be the simple truth and the simple truth
is they
they're ready they're ready to have a
fascist state they're [ __ ] they've
been ready for a long time but they want
it so bad and they feel like it's so
close because a former president can
stand up on stage and say i want to
pardon all the insurrectionists that
help me do an uh cheeto dust kangaroo
talk about that because what gift what
kind of [ __ ] gift is that in this
2022 midterm like like trump should be
staying quiet so that all the
republicans can run and take the house
but he's not he's not staying quiet he's
giving us all the ammunition we need it
is but you know at the end of the day in
the wrong maker's hands that creative is
not going to have the same power right
so it's like one [ __ ] thing to tell
middle america hey donald trump is on
stage talking about partying and
correctionist and overturning the
government but unless you make a
connection to them and why that should
scare the [ __ ] out of them personally
for their own children for their own job
for their own you know um political
freedom then you're not gonna get the
same value right so it's it you know
it's good that i want people to copy
that i want people to copy like yes we
we must make sure if we're gonna move
the generic ballot and the enthusiasm
gap we have two things we must
accomplish okay number one we gotta make
republicans as unpopular as we are right
now and we're in power and they're not
so we have to make them visible we're
the only [ __ ] ones that can do it
okay
and number two right like so like that's
i mean that's a crucial thing if that's
the generic ballot we have to make them
the news story every day between now and
election day and then we'd see generic
we could see generic ballot move okay
and then number two is our enthusiasm
problem because here's the thing
all of this [ __ ] that's going on that's
actual tangible
you know
first wave fascism is happening
and yet here in our party amongst
democrats and leaners
we are less concerned about the status
of democracy
than the people and the party that are
attacking democracy and that's because
in their propaganda system as tony just
pointed out
they have been told we're the ones that
stole an election they think that
they're living in a rogue state dude and
like that's mass psychosis it's
incredibly dangerous but it's also a
political reality that you can see in
data they are like frothing at the bit
for 2022 and right now we do not have a
system in place to answer that i'm
working very hard right our our frothing
is not the same it's not the same
frothing right no it's 15 point deficit
all right
i mean yes at the end of the day tony
you're right the throttling is not the
same either right i mean we're we're
seeing people advocate openly now for
political violence right that michigan
state legislature which i don't know
about that i i i do have that let me go
real quick to because i i want to play
the quick clip of this [ __ ] [ __ ]
what that
saying how many people have been asking
me about it
if i run and if i win
we will treat those people from january
6th fairly
we will treat them fairly
and if it requires pardons we will give
them parts okay that's enough of that
[ __ ] um so that that's
that's where he's saying hey i'm going
to commit sedition like radon he [ __ ]
opened like he's not even he's not
hiding it well let's read what you had
to say here maybe just maybe media could
start questioning republicans about
their continuous support of this lawless
madmen rather than rather than
normalizing it um you know that's
another problem that we have is the
media i think is stuck in this trump
loop that's what i call it they're so
used to covering trump for like five
years they just can't pluck their head
out of their [ __ ] asses to understand
um what's going on here's ron had this
this is the video you're talking about
right
okay so let's listen to this because
it's like over a minute but it is
[ __ ] worth listening to because this
this is their plan they've got a backup
plan and they're getting people [ __ ]
geared up towards violence listen to
this [ __ ]
and like 160 of them that were
republicans right we want 50 50. if you
see something
the second amendment
to is all the others so so here's here's
the gear up number one i'm not sure who
these [ __ ] are but the one [ __ ]
says oh if you see something you don't
like just walk up to the voting machine
and unplug it number one do not do that
whether you're democrat republican don't
[ __ ] try to [ __ ] with the voting
machines
don't don't do that you you definitely
will be you definitely be charged with
something um don't do that if if
but this is their plan their plan is to
create chaos don't you believe that
oh i absolutely believe that i mean i
know it's not a belief thing right i
mean right
this is this is their plan to not not
only create chaos inside the polling
places um because that's because that's
like oh they're going to steal it like
they were un can you i can already see
it rachel like they're like to be clear
this is a man that's that's either a
michigan state delegate or
wants to be a michigan delegate okay
and probably will be elected i mean
people i mean people need to understand
like
it's so comforting to think oh well
there's just no way that somebody could
look at ron johnson and was in wisconsin
especially you know all this crazy [ __ ]
that he says that he's going to be
competitive and the fact of the matter
is because the turnout is going to go
down
republicans are going to oh it's not
just about up and down turnout right so
a lot of people are like oh down the
look democrats lose high turnout
elections yeah no i it's always been
about the coalition of that turnout
right right right dominated by
republicans and right-leaning
independents which today it's gonna be
based on that generic ballot and the
enthusiasm gap right we know that so
it's not about belief it's it's no right
and then um you know we we need to make
it clear like this these people are all
electable okay ron desantis is running
his donations on jailing [ __ ] dr bocce
dude right right well and he's
his surgeon general is basically saying
the same [ __ ] the person who's in charge
of help in florida is saying the same
[ __ ] garbage and they're parroting it
all the way down let and speaking of
parroting let's let's listen to what
this [ __ ] says about arming themselves
if i can get there we go
the ideal thing
is
i love that where he's like we're
definitely going to have to be violent
and we want you violent like you're just
saying it out loud you dumb [ __ ]
yeah the
we have to do this peacefully let's all
show up armed at the polls right here we
go watch
if we can't change the tide like so if
democrats show up to vote in large
numbers to make sure that they elect
democratically the government that they
want we have to make sure we're willing
to stand in their way and shoot and kill
them like he's saying it out loud
i mean come on dude we all know what
that [ __ ] means we all and it's
fascist as [ __ ]
how how we can't use this and that you
know that that's that's enough of this
[ __ ] guy um but i mean how we how we
can't figure out hey we need to use this
we need to point this in a direction so
that we not only have that turnout but
we have the correct coalition to turn
out to get this vote where we need it
because i believe and i think you
believe the same thing if we can create
this strategic outrage we can stay
pissed we can get people to go [ __ ]
vote because democrats are only the only
party that's going to deliver us
democracy republicans obviously want to
destroy it and they want to cut it off
and cut it down like a [ __ ] fresh-cut
tree so if what we have to do though is
if we can create this coalition for that
turnout we not only can win the house
and the senate we can win some of these
state races we can win governorships we
can do all this
but we have to we have to focus on that
strategic outrage and they're giving us
all the little chicken nuggets that we
need to make this strategic outrage work
don't you think
yeah i mean we and you know what we
already know all of this [ __ ] works
because we can watch the other party do
it in action and they executed the best
version of it ever in history as crt
which is a
nationalized campaign but it's so
sophisticated that the reporters keep
calling it local right right right
that's how good they're at they've been
running this the system i want to put in
place now for almost 20 years and it's
very very good now right it's not it's
not like the like of the weak [ __ ] like
they started off their weeks off [ __ ] in
2010 looked like the mcauliffe campaigns
[ __ ] this cycle okay so like you know
that's why i said it's simple but not
simplistic and we can't afford the
evolution so let's skip the evolution
since it's already in my brain and just
get to the ass beaten right let's let's
put the [ __ ] let's well or take the
gloves off and let's [ __ ] fight yeah
because i i can tell you i can deliver
for us sophisticated nationalized
campaigns that look like local politics
too and then we can use it to at least
force in 22 which is a midterm cycle
against us because we're the party in
power at least force a referendum
conversation on the other side because
the 22 is naturally a referendum on us
and if we are the only thing it's a
referendum on we are going to lose
right well and that that comes with the
consequences and i don't think people
understand what fascism brings like your
job that you have the nice little church
that you go to the schools that your
children go to all that stuff is not
going to exist if they have what they
want
your nice little cushy american
lifestyle that all goes away that's
right all of it it's not
they get to decide
when they take over when they have a
fascist state it is not a situation
where oh we're gonna make it peachy and
keen and it's it'll be cool with the
fascists in charge no they will take
everything away from you all of it you
will not have the [ __ ] life that you
have now you will not get up to go to
the same job you will not go to the same
church you will your kids will not go to
the school that you know today it will
not that is what they want they want
this to be torn apart because
they see what's coming with democracy
and democracy is the enemy of fascism
and that's why they want to tear it down
they say [ __ ] you know people like oh
don't post his statement and on the
other side they say we don't have a
democracy get the [ __ ] out of here with
that [ __ ]
we we know what you mean when you say
that we fascists don't want democracy
because democracy is our enemy and the
reason why it's their enemy is because
they really do want to tear apart our
country and they want to tell you what
the [ __ ] to do they want to tell your
family you call them breakfast snarks
right and then and that the phrase you
use
yeah no i mean here's the thing
you know i think it's really important
to keep everything in context right so
like okay let's say republicans win
congress in 22. let's say in that wave
it's so large that they also flip the
governorships of michigan pennsylvania
wisconsin all of which are up this cycle
and suddenly you go into 24 instead of
having you know states that are
managing elections for the purpose of
democratic accountability instead manage
elections for partisan outcome
and you tell me you want to go into 24
with that right i don't
and the reason is is that you know it's
not like it's like oh republicans like
let's say they they win in 24 because
they curtail the electorate down all
right it's not like they're gonna
announce the next day some kind of ban
on you know
democrats working in the civil service
right it's gonna be discreet and it's
going to be slow but it will impact you
and your children and your children's
children and it will not be in a good
way right we have a um we have a lot of
problems in america we've always had a
lot of problems but in general actually
have been making good progress on some
of these things that's why they're
fighting back so
um you know intensely to the point where
they're willing to dismantle
real democracy and america will go on
and have elections right but if you're
if you're curtailing the electorate if
you're
choosing who's in the salad before the
votes are cast
guys that's not democracy right
like you're articulating the outcome
based on who can participate in the
election you know so well well i i mean
their goal their goal is to choose their
voters i mean that that is their goal um
because if they don't choose their
voters and and we do pile them under
mountains and mountains of votes uh the
fascist state that they want will not
succeed i mean it just won't because
again the only pro-democracy party which
i i wish we were
you know a different maybe a different
setup of democracy where we had more
than two parties but we're not that's
not the reality you can you can yell and
scream about a third party all you want
and all this [ __ ] but it's not a reality
it is not we live in a political reality
where we have two parties and the other
political reality that we have is only
one
one of those [ __ ] is for
democracy anymore and really honestly i
believe it's been about
i think it's been 20 or 30 years since
there's been one party that really has
been
um
very
pro-democracy and the other one has you
know thin veiled their fascism with
debts and deficits and all this [ __ ] you
know that's what the liz cheney thing is
they want that party back um but there
are some people in the party steve
bannon donald trump all the fascists out
there they definitely do not want that
kind of fascism they want full-on 100
fascism out front i mean that's why he's
saying what he's saying in his rallies
that's why he's saying what he's saying
in the statements don't you think i mean
yeah yeah i mean
i think sometimes i have to wake up in
the morning and like look at myself
actually is all this [ __ ] just that it's
so flagrant and so ignored
like it's it's actually quite
fascinating in terms of criminology
right okay so it turns out like
committing crimes in plain sight with a
propaganda network you know no problem
right
you're better off doing it just
flavoring i mean they're so flake i mean
they did the whole
everyone talks about january 6 and even
in the fall post-election monkeying
around in the electorate but they were
doing that [ __ ] six months before the
the republicans anytime a republican
tells you well that it technically you
know there was still fraud because the
state legislative governors overrode the
state legislatures and blah blah blah
well the reason they had to do that is
because the gop would not let people
remote vote during a [ __ ] deadly
pandemic when there was no vaccine right
so it's not like like the governor's
overrode the state legislatures and
that's the beginning of the story right
you leave out the entire first chapter
of the context of where the gop is like
oh deadly pandemic screw you you can't
vote in public because we want less
people to vote so we can win right and
uh you know we we just have to make sure
like it
because i think it is so plain sight
everyone assumes everyone sees it i
guarantee you walk around a grocery
store go go somewhere with your friends
and ask them about the eastman
they'll be like who they're gonna have
right they have no idea power plot you
know they have no idea about any of that
[ __ ] and if we don't make it an issue if
we don't make it as salient as
deflategate which i was talking about
today where you know saturation coverage
and everyone's talking about did the new
england patriots deflate their ball and
here's all the standard protocols for
bull handling [ __ ] we're all experts on
balls in the nfl right right we could be
experts on democratic collapse too if
the media was talking about it more
that's right well the other thing too on
the other side of the coin
their side their coalition they know all
of it yep
all of it well they know their equation
well correct i mean they're they know
they know their misinformation and lies
we know that just by the way that
they've been able to employ the the crt
voodoo [ __ ] and they did that [ __ ] on
purpose tony like so here they come out
of january 6 and there was an initial
recoil of some of that coalition that
you were talking about the beginning of
the interview so there was some initial
like okay that's finally it the bridge
too far i mean bribing the ukrainian
president i was fine with i guess but
not this right
so there was like this initial dip but
then what the republicans did is they
deployed fox and right wing media to
start normalizing january january 6 and
recasting it as a protest that was never
an insurrection remember all the rewrite
that the fox news people got in trouble
with because their private texts
revealed they knew damn well it was
insurrection that trump was like behind
it right so you know when we think about
that like we need we really need um
people talking about what's happening
telling everyone about it forcing them
to look friends or my friends too are
like oh you know i i didn't know any of
this you know and they're highly they
vote every election so we have to tell
people if we want them to know so so
you're saying that there's people out
there that vote on issues that they
don't know about oh my gosh that
almost everybody votes on one issue and
that's party okay right and even in that
conversion pool of independence for most
of them 85
party is going to condition their vote
even if they don't admit it to
themselves through the process of the
campaign right
um and you know when we talk about
coalitional turnout in the republican
model what they figured out was how to
keep their coalition engaged between
presidential and midterms
so turnout might go up and down but
their turnout stays pretty constant in
fact has gone up over over years even
when they're in
power and that is a product of how they
election year the modeling that they're
using the messaging the strategy that we
can replicate and if we can do that guys
we actually can survive 22 so i don't
want to leave everybody saying it's
hopeless but i'd also i'm not a
bullshitter so i'm not going to sit here
and tell you when the data is clear the
generic ballot and the enthusiasm gap
are the two indicators that we need to
watch and we need to move and if we
can't move them we're going to be in
real trouble in the fall no matter what
biden's approval rating is no matter
what's going on in the headlines so so
before we go um because it sounds like
i'm going to have another guest coming
here soon a really big name is going to
come on the show here
um and you can stick around in the green
room to watch if you want um but
explain one more time that
what you're talking about the generic
ballot what is that in terms of what
does that actually [ __ ] mean what
what are those things because
you know i think this is one thing that
liberals do is they they pile data on
someone and it's like you don't really
don't need to do that you just need to
is make it simple as possible so what
does that actually mean what does that
look like to you when you're looking at
the data but when everyone out there is
looking at it what do they need to see
what do they need to know about that
people can track the congressional
generic ballot on the 538 website very
easy by googling that and it will show
you uh two lines one's for democrats and
one's for republicans and it is
indicating in national survey data
from people
which party do you want to control
congress in 22 and yeah republican or
democrat right right in 2018 really from
the moment 2017 got going with trump
democrats led that and led it
substantially and they must lead it
substantially because as everyone knows
their vote is more concentrated in urban
and suburban places so they have to over
perform the national generic ballot by
at least four or five points to be
competitive to hold on to congress
in my opinion
right so you can track that at 5 38 yes
and and and like the way that you would
move me so like
what what this what this what this
indicates to us right is the conversion
preference basically of that pure
independent and pure independence under
my research i argue look they're largely
imagistic they're not
well-informed people okay they don't
even really care much about politics
they don't know a lot of what they when
i talk about people who don't know
what's going on these people are
definitely in that they know about tom
brady football but
only what the national narrative top
line conversation right it's gonna be
the chiefs lost yesterday the chiefs
lost yes a tornado devastates everything
so you have to make your conversation so
benghazi right but republicans made
benghazi a household name how did they
do it they used control of the committee
process and they kept having all of
these news cycles about benghazi and
pounding it and pounding it and like
people would be like oh this is so
important
right crt same way right so you can't
democrats want to look at polling data
there's many ways we we misuse polling
data we do a whole episode on that but
one of the most important ways is we ask
the public what's important to you and
then we like craft our campaign strategy
on that and republicans say what's good
for us politically we'll make that
salient and we'll make the election
occur on those lines and that's what i'm
arguing it succinctly we need to do here
in 22.
well thank you rachel for joining us
come back anytime maybe maybe they'll
give us some more ammunition
to fight for democracy i'm sure they'll
pile it on this week
as they try to hopefully the media will
try to get people to explain these
politicians explain why they're still
standing behind a president who's
calling for a coup and who's saying he
tried to overturn the election he's
gonna pardon the people who help him
which he had the opportunity and he
didn't do it so it kind of makes no
sense to me i got to say i'm sorry i'm
going to sign off i am going to listen
in the green room though because i think
you guys are going to want to stay tuned
yeah
very special that's right i i i think we
got maybe someone who can tell us about
the rally this weekend thanks rachel for
joining us we'll see you next time have
a good one we'll see you soon
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michael